hello everyone and welcome to another
educational but also fun video since you
enjoyed the previous one so much i
decided to throw in
another one uh this one is uh
checkmating with a bishop and
knight a lot of you guys have suggested
it and uh
it also uh works nicely while we're
waiting for the tournament of legends
that is starting very soon
so basically uh what's happening here is
that uh
white has a bishop and the knight and
black has only a king and white needs to
deliver checkmate and there are
there are a few methods you can use to
achieve this i decided to only show the
the one that i think is the simplest one
and then if you guys
think it's necessary then we can maybe
do the other one as well
uh but basically what you want to do
here and let me just show you something
it's uh
this is just from wikipedia there you
can see uh
all of the possible things that can
happen so in short
there's the diagram a which is what will
usually happen so this is uh the
checkmate that will happen most often
the black king in the corner
the same corner of the bishop that you
have then you have diagram b
it's a an alternate checkmate that can
happen then you have diagram c
and alternate checkmate that cannot be
forced which
we will show during this video then you
have an ultra alternate checkmate that
cannot be forced
the the one that's d uh also in the
middle of the board but
where the bishop delivers checkmate then
you have an alternate checkmate that can
be forced
diagram e uh and uh there you have
the the checkmate in the wrong corner
that cannot be forced
so basically you always want to uh force
the king into the corner of your own
bishop
uh but even though it's possible to
deliver checkmate in the other corner
it's only possible if your opponent
plays
really bad so here we are only going to
consider moves that are
good for both sides and uh from the
worst possible position
you can do the checkmating sequence in
33 moves which is very important as you
have to do it before the 50 move rule
if you are not successful in delivering
checkmate within 50 moves your opponent
can claim the 50 move rule and
the game will be proclaimed a draw so
this is uh this is a standard position
that we'll be using to
to show what's happening here so
basically uh there are three phases of
how you want to deliver checkmate first
is
uh you wanna drive the king uh to the
edge of the board because of course
uh black knows how to deliver checkmate
or we're presuming that black nose and
he will try to remain in the center of
the board
as long as he's in the center he cannot
get checkmated so that that's what he's
gonna do so uh the first part is getting
the king
uh somewhere to the edge of the board it
doesn't really matter where
uh then it's forcing the king uh into
the right corner or basically forcing
the king from the wrong corner into the
right corner here we have a light square
bishop
and we can only checkmate the black king
in one of these corners we cannot do it
or maybe
let's do it with the green color so we
cannot do it
on the red corners we can only do it on
the green corners and of course
phase three is delivering the actual
checkmate so here
the way we want to do it is we wanna uh
get some squares uh
for our king so the the black king is
currently preventing us from reaching
any of these squares and we want to
push him back so here let's say the
bishop and knight and the king are
boxing the black king
as well and he needs to move back so
he's going to move back
trying to remain in the center of the
board and okay we want some squares now
so
we uh bring our king into the as close
to the black king as possible
he will again make a move he cannot use
this d square so he will try to remain
in the center of the board and we just
play king e3
and now i know uh notice that uh none of
the central squares are possible anymore
now he has to play something else so
let's say he plays king to f5
and now we bring the knight into the
game knight to d3 we take away the e5
square from the black king and again
black to move he has to play something
and okay he's gonna play king
g5 and now comes the move that you
should remember uh bishop to e4 so this
is the setup that we want to get
or again let's make it green so with
this king bishop and knight setup we are
creating
uh well maybe a red square we are
creating a wall here
and it's quite a big wall and the black
kink will not be able to cross this wall
uh and he will only be able to use some
of the other squares which is good for
us
as we know that he's probably gonna try
and hide into the dark square corner so
we're gonna uh he's gonna
try and remain as close as possible to
the center and we go king d4
we bring our king closer to his king so
king is six
and now king to c5 notice that after
we achieved this setup we will mostly be
playing with our king
so king to e7 now again there's a wall
here now you should never forget this
wall
it's always here and now we are boxing
in the king even further with our own
king so king is seven
and now king the d5 taking away even
more squares king of six we're gonna go
play
king d6 again we take the opposition the
king has to move he has to move
somewhere it doesn't really matter where
uh and the king to e5 now and now uh
and sorry about that yeah only heard it
now uh and now we've reached the e5
square and again
uh we are boxing the black king in so
notice that if the black king starts
marching towards the light square corner
that's good for us we want him there
because that's the only corner aside
from this one of course where we can
check made him so
he's probably going to go to the other
corner so he's going to go king g7
we're going to follow him king e6 uh
he's going to go king to g8 and now
or he doesn't have to go here he can go
here he can go here he can go here
uh but uh as soon as he touches the
corner uh we are
bringing in the knight so knight comes
to e5 and now the knight will be used
so we can drive the king away from the
h8 square the knight from f7 and the g6
uh can force the king back as we're
controlling this diagonal with the
bishop
knight to f7 will be what drives the
king back from the corner
so king f8 and we're gonna go king to f6
he's gonna repeat king g8 and now we go
knight to f7 and now the knight covers
the h8 square the bishop covers the h7
score so he he needs to go back and now
that we have the king all the way
back into the corner now we will try to
get him all the way to the light square
corner so we can deliver checkmate
so he goes king f8 and now we go bishop
to h7
uh we just take away the g8 square and
force the king to go further
further left so king e8 and now
we can go knight to e5 we need to now go
knight e5 uh
to d7 to c5 so 95
now the knight also covers the d7 square
so the king cannot escape the back rank
uh and of course he's gonna try to go
back king f8 but we're just going to go
knight to d7 check now he's going to go
back and now
king to e6 now again the king is boxing
the
black king in so he's going to try uh
well he doesn't have anything to try he
only has one move king to d8 and now
we're gonna go king to d6
he's gonna of course try to go back to
the wrong
corner uh and bishop the g6 check now
now we are covering both of these
squares uh and he needs to go back to
the center so king d8
and now we shift the knight to c5 so
like we said from f7 to e5 to
d7 to c5 uh he only has one move king to
c8 and now we're going to go
bishop to e4 we we want to get our
bishop
to c6 uh so when the king starts running
back to the wrong corner we're gonna
deliver this bishop to d7 check
uh and this will force the king further
to the left and
here is uh what happened so he's to go
king to d8
we're going to go bishop to c6 he's
going to go king to c8 hoping to repeat
this but now we trick him now we play
bishop to d7 check
and now he can no longer go here because
we
get one of those checkmates that
actually cannot be forced if he goes
here then it's just knight to e6
checkmate
uh and of course black will never do
this but if he does uh
just so you know so now we get to force
him even further back to the left so
king to b8
and now comes king to c6 and now with
the bishop covering this and the knight
covering this
uh the black king is not escaping uh
well his tomb so to say so he's gonna go
king to a7 you're gonna go king to c7
he's gonna go king to a8 and now once
you've touched
uh once you touch the b6 square uh now
it's
just over he has two more moves he's
gonna go king to b8 and now you deliver
knight a6 check and finally after the
only move possible king to a8 you're
gonna deliver bishop the c6 checkmate
so that's basically it that's how you do
it i decided not to show the other
method
as i was trying to make it as simple as
possible and
this method does seem a little a little
bit simpler than the other one where you
have to
uh make triangles uh with your pieces
and
here you basically just put your pieces
uh in the middle of the board and you've
already created a nice wall
uh here after this bishop to e4 move
like we mentioned
and now with uh with the understanding
that we've created a wall here
everything else seems to be pretty
reasonable uh if the king
goes to this corner you know how to
drive him back you will bring the knight
let's say to e5 then
then to f7 uh and if he goes to the
either of the two light square corners
uh
this is good for us because in those
corners we can deliver checkmate
uh so yeah that's uh that's basically it
bishop the c6 is checkmate and
although you can checkmate your opponent
uh in different ways if he plays poorly
if he plays the best possible moves of
course he will try try to remain in the
center for as long as possible and then
he will try to go to the wrong corner
then you have to
force him to the right corner and then
you have to deliver checkmate there
as uh uh he will of course be hoping
that uh
you you will either blunder something or
maybe he can
uh like maybe he can uh grab
ah create a double attack against your
knight and bishop with the kings or
maybe he can create some sort of a
stalemate
he will try a lot of things and of
course the stronger your opponent is the
the more you will have to struggle
uh but if you know this uh basic
principle you should be okay
now uh you're not gonna get this
position very often in life
i've i i mean i haven't played all that
much chess but i have played
uh a decent amount of over the board
chess and i
only got this position once in classical
chess over the board
uh i had the white pieces uh i was
playing against the candidate master and
i had
i i got this position king and uh bishop
and knight against the the king
and i was able to find the the correct
sequence even even though i didn't know
the exact uh
continuations i knew that i need to
drive uh the king to the to the right
corner of my bishop and then
i i was able to find the moves but it's
because it was a classical game
and i had i don't know maybe maybe even
half an hour on the clock so
it wasn't really a stressful situation
and but it doesn't help to to know like
if you have very little time on the
clock
that it is possible to do it i don't
know who did it someone
posted on twitter that they actually got
to this position either in bullet or or
a blitz game with one minute on the
clock and that they were able to do it
with one minute on the clock
so if you know it uh you know you will
yeah you will definitely
make use of it uh but yeah that's
uh the video i do hope you enjoyed it
and that it will help you at least once
or twice in your life
uh or if not um you can just simply
impress your friends at the bar
in the library uh i would like to thank
suleiman albalvi
uh even mithruchev uh paramat sangavar
edward smith and uh avinash dinesh
shilaya for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the paul
morphy saga checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
and if you enjoy more educational and
fun videos like these uh do mention
something so i know to create more
thank you all and i will see you soon